des feuilles les vignes pour préparer le
raisin la récolte quand ils pensent aux
heures de labeur qui l'attendent
david souris match est carrément
contents ils faire les vendanges
cela fait un an que ce jeune de 27 ans
n'a pour seul revenu que le rsa suivis
par pôle emploi il ne parvient pas à
trouver d'emploi stable dans son domaine
le bâtiment ce dispositif rsa vendanges
l'occasion pour lui de se relancer
faire les vendanges et cumulait le rsa
c'est encourageant pour nous quoi lancer
bien pour le portefeuille le moral et
après ça nous mettra le coup de boost
pour reprendre le boulot quoi si on a un
bon élément il nous rappellerons en plus
du rsa david percevra donc un salaire le
même que celui des autres saisonniers
nicole bott et cogérante de bottes frère
est fier d'employer des vendangeurs
allocataires du rsa
si on peut les aider à rester dans la
course et à savoir qu'on est utile c'est
valorisant pour eux c'est aussi notre
rôle de donner une chance à aux
personnes qui sont bénéficiaires du rsa
selon un premier bilan de pôle emploi
plus de 95% des annonces de vendangeurs
saisonniers ont trouvé preneur dans le
département brigitte klinkert et
présidente du conseil départemental du
haut rhin et c'est pour elle la preuve
que le dispositif rsa vendanges mérite
l'attention du gouvernement je souhaite
que le gouvernement justement entendre
les résultats de cette expérimentation
que nous venons de faire dans l'urne je
souhaite que cette expérience puisse
être élargie à d'autres domaines
d'activité dans le haut-rhin 33 mille
personnes touchent le rsa selon le
conseil général 23 mille postes restent
à pourvoir